the last time we talked it was about a
year ago we talked about your SMS audio
headphones since then I am we launched
and actually it says available in 46
countries and not only that but now you
have a bunch of new business ventures
including a new book by a boxing
promotions company you have tons of new
TV and film projects a new album and
more philanthropy but you're here to
talk about the book right now
right yeah is that your big push right
now it is because I you know I had an
opportunity the music actually traveling
in 2003 I traveled so far up from almost
320 times stay here while I was
everywhere and that that actual process
it took me so many new places digested
and I put people from different walks of
life and different cultures and I wasn't
I'm not like the Explorer as far as food
is concerned you know what they're not a
risk-taker they're different food
standards different territories that I
was in because I was travelling around
the world and I stuck to what was a
comfortable thing and it was the fast
food change they traveled really I mean
big and I came back and I was the
massacre the second album 2005 there if
you look at the cover I actually had to
draw the where the cuts was supposed to
be at all I started to soften up like so
a nutritionist you hired a nutritionist
and the trainer to travel with me in it
and for a huge time period information
that's in this book I acquired it you
know my hands-on type of situation over
over that time the the money that I
spent I felt like it just informed me a
ways that the general public has known
it's not really conscious of okay so
you're offering that advice in this book
it's called formula 50 the 6-week
workout a nutrition plan that will
transform your life right what are the
two or three things that you would say
that differentiate this book from all of
the other ones
are out there on health and fitness I
mean just the language the way I
actually convey what I'm trying to
message points you know and because I
don't accept no as an answer you know
you know me try again to me like you're
going to business and I keep it like
that so when if I get the answer it's
not a big enough letdown to stop me from
not going after my actual goal so I
think when they actually get a chance to
see what a regimen when you have someone
to make reference of the discipline
themselves in that way it may be someone
that's inspired by the culture and
hip-hop culture is now pop culture's
everywhere and you know so they may take
a look at it because it's coming from
someone sometimes they view the message
well yeah I mean before they even get to
take a look at the message I mean the
idea that you've been able to transform
your body in the way that you did for
the movie when you lost all that weight
and then you've been ripped up at
various times you're cut up now I mean
people respect that and they're aware of
that narrative is that the case because
you don't get a free moment now
technology allows the actual fans to be
closer to you than usual my projection
is to disappear and then come back
disappeared and come back only person
within our culture that can do that is
in my new reporting one person and all
the hip-hop culture that disappears and
then you don't see or know anything
about what he's actually doing and then
you see when he comes back with the next
record
why is he able to do that well he
doesn't really involve himself always
not really active outside of music so it
just yeah does well when the music is
out and he's moving around a little bit
to promote it and then he goes in and it
just stays until it's time to launch it
again so there's no change in perception
of who he is or what he is outside of
the last thing you heard from there
musically right you know so it makes it
a little easier like with me I found
myself at my fifth and final requirement
for in scope at that point you got to go
through audit and when you find areas
where you feel like you're supposed to
be paid at different points
kind of wait until everybody is seeing
things the same way and they actually
pay out and then you go ahead and do
what you got to do so now we're at a
point where I can actually launch the
music but in between time because it was
a three year hiatus that we were going
through that actual process I've been
active visible and working oh my girls
so they see me still sustaining my
interest within music culture by doing
different things that I do promotional
purposes and then seeing me in business
and other areas so it just changes my
aura shifts me a little bit to more
business than artists at different
points and it's only because of the
portion of the music business that last
half music business the business part is
when you go through the politics or the
the actual the workings of each
individual that's involved in the actual
deal and so you've really transcended
far beyond where you started from but
people tend to still keep you in the
tight cast role and it's something that
really fascinates me
music business medicine it that you
become the song you know my first album
I wrote all the dysfunctional behaviors
an environment that I'm from you know I
even put them high all the time when I
don't actually use drugs I just knew
that they were received that well with
all the other dysfunctional content
there was an actual record it just
managed and I've seen artists previously
sell 500,000 copies consistently with
those messaging points mm-hmm and even
more when it was College when his aim
and the content was aimed at college as
I see our four men selling million
records would I was supposed to do my
homework and then I got high yeah you
know like so is that and Kanye was the
college dropout that was hip anemic
right is that's a target in that market
you know totally you know so so because
you transformed it you've evolved so
much because you've been around the
world you've you've acquired wealth and
you've done all of these things will
there ever be a point where you're not
tight cash
that's it bother you no it doesn't you
know I learned how to navigate people in
that way you know so the one time that
they felt a little a little
uncomfortable is where it was
I approached feeding America as I had
experience going Africa and that's way
more extremely low-income housing right
you know so it makes you evaluate with
you when you thought you had nothing to
lose you were making decisions based on
that
we see someone but less than you
actually had at that point and you got
say well what was our basing my
decisions on at that point because if I
was under those circumstances I'd have
been happy to be in the position I was
in mm-hmm
you know and it made me want to do a
project but the street cane project
energy drink that I chose the category
because we think is on the packaging
goods it was only one category was a
billion dollar category with one player
and their target audience was like 30
and up you know and could they follow
our energy was targeting truck drivers
at that point it's a necessity to stay
awake but all right make sense and this
is why all the gas stations and all
those areas because it's like an impulse
buy Danika shot and I said this is cool
I just target a younger demographic
because hip hop culture is a youth food
driven art form of course targeting that
demo I would have to have the product
taste better
mmm-hmm 5rn is fine if it tastes like
medication misawa's right honey did you
take it I feel like I'm up now I just
had my medicine right and I'm up and you
know that the energy in there actually
drinks come from natural b12 b6 so it's
equivalent to like two and a half cups
of coffee I ended up partnering with the
United Nations World Food Program
because my first efforts to do something
with feeding America wasn't received
they were a little uneasy at that image
you said being typecast or really
whether you should actually be working
with 50 cent and it kind of felt like
when you're calling it oh I got to get
this one hit back from my supervisor or
from whatever
else that like these people say that
they don't actually want the money I'm
very good
you know if it's interesting because the
who is actually giving the tornado I'm
not sure we want to be associated with
that because of the content when the
work nine nations for a food program
when that deal is made and they see all
the positive publicity and press it
comes back around full circle so you
know I didn't shy away from the second
time because you know my intentions were
to actually help out so and really the
goal there is to feed a billion kids
right this concept of conscious
capitalism so your the energy drink is
making money but the idea is to help
right
eradicate the hunger your order
deprogram people from wanting to be
entrepreneurs or wanting to live life on
the highest level you know and I
respected that if the person wants that
they don't then I'm not sure I need to
be in communications with them mm-hmm
cuz you know if people that you actually
associate yourself with if they don't
have the same kind of goals and
conversation you can be going in circles
so you're not growing you're growing I
not only have you done that now you're
in boxing promotion you have Gamboa and
the one thing about that that fight that
fascinated me was that you work the
phones you were a promoter you performed
at the show you used your advantage you
leveraged your advantage of who you were
do you think that the people that
thought that you wouldn't be successful
as a boxing promoter saw that value that
night absolutely and and they saw that
that was the biggest cart butter year
babies fight would be in a manatee
market right you know so to position
them to combat on that actual part was
it was definitely the right movement
position for cowboy he's aware of it
because he looks in it and I direct
Association he gets more people to just
out of interest right what was he like
even if our coaches all conditioned for
a battle consistent
so when you pick a person like he's like
oh this is his fighter now you're going
to start finding other artists wanting
to be associated with fighters they may
not necessarily be ended enough to be a
promoter wearing on the actual fighter
but some sort of association and work
with the actual fighters and I may comes
by way of the aggression necessary to
compete on some levels within the
culture I think he speaks directly to
the fighters and then internalize it in
a different way because it takes their
mind off of the discipline involved were
performing on that level how much work
has to be done in actual gym the music's
plan you know the road work the
headphones on they running the music's
playing
grain you know so there's a connection a
strong connection with music called
sandbox particularly your music right
you know in the club that isn't
something you can run to forever but
it's so funny my man because Manny
Pacquiao works out - Shakira yeah some
people that by different thing I've been
in the gym that guy it is hilarious man
because it's just run so counter to what
you would think that a buddy actually
aren't be able no yeah that is same
together yeah so he's you know I can see
him have an interest in that it wasn't
necessarily an impressive win but it was
a win right and it got you started and I
think it is whoa - when the W did
actually championship is always
impressive he is that level of fighter
the a great level of item which you saw
with many Marquez is what happens when
you got a level fighters they are many
beat Marcus three times before that yes
and and in my actual scorecards was
winning that fight until that punch
because a guy would with that kind of
professional time and work put into you
know being that kind of fighter always
has a punch his chance
hmm you know and it can look down to one
punch it came through that night six
seconds left and around Marquez nose
broke blood all over the place those six
seconds go by without that overhand
right landing to have to stop the next
one
was there a little truth to the
criticism man hey you know this guy
thinks he can come into boxing now
because he's been friends with Floyd
Mayweather but it's a lot harder than it
looks
did you find was there were there things
that were a lot harder than they look
well the old boys club doesn't like
anything new but the old way that
thinking is what pushes all of the top
fighters towards me hmm can you help
them with the tradition the promoters
have beat two fighters out of the money
when it's not my primary income I don't
have interest in that I actually got
involved with the sport because I'm
passionate about it no it's actually
boxers losing the UFC right the entire
sport is losing it needs new energy
needs new excitement involvement it
needs a different way of thinking like I
only want to be associated with the top
fighters because I don't want to have to
run as a promoter I don't have to run
from the top talent so the fight as it
comes got to be aware that we're gonna
fight your credit it really looks right
yeah and and that's that's just my
concept I don't want to be associated
with fighters that are in portions of
the career with a ducking and dodging
mm-hmm opponents that they feel like are
you know stronger than so you're really
in this for the long haul this isn't
exactly I mean I - in the pan originally
the concept comes because I'm kept
closer to the actual sport of boxing
because my friends are the top fighters
in it and know before that I had a
passion for the sport it just wasn't
something that was right in my face
every day like when I get on the phone
and say hey what you're doing just to
talk and you go yeah well they told my
supposed to fight this person I was not
and I'll find them but come on they
gotta pay the right money yeah well you
have news conversations just because you
decide to take a break from what your
business is to just talk to a friend
it'll help shape what changes you think
can be made
to how things work to make it you know
to it benefit the entire sport of course
you were friends with Floyd Mayweather
you're not anymore right okay you have a
lot of falling outs with friends and it
seems like a lot of it has to do with
when money becomes involved you do
business like whether it's the game or
whether it's him or other people when
money becomes involved there's a problem
is that the case or not well this is
good well Floyd in Floyd's case that's a
where it actually came when you got
involved is you were partners yeah an
actual business but and those other
situations it wasn't about money even
though we had work relationships okay it
was more about some people feel like
they can't be as big as they can be
around you because if you actually are
the source of why people are coming they
want the focus to be on them so they
remove themselves from that circle and
aid antagonize the situation and because
they were publicly connected to you
people pay attention to it mm-hmm
you know if I don't offer the energy in
the beginning to make them recognizable
it wouldn't you know these people are
you know and having those those fall
outs for people that actually close to
you is no difference between and in the
other case we have relationships with
people they grow apart or they go have
different ideas doesn't hurt you know
it's just it's more have to be a better
judge of character and not utilize
myself as a marketing tool for people
when I don't make so much of an effort
to get them in position if they if it
works then you did it the thing doesn't
feel like I did all this work to get you
in the position that you're in and then
you start to just do something different
and they don't resent you the whole time
because they know that it came from
being associated with you right this is
when they become open to resolving
things I've had several artists come
around and after they start to gain a
little momentum they start to feel like
it's me like
it's me some of them have openly
expressed it to German public and others
have kept it quiet but personally felt
the same feelings to learn about folk
you know so the human spirit is
comprised of a lot of things but ego is
at the top of it one of the things that
about you is just the way that you walk
about and carry yourself you've had a
tremendous amount of success but somehow
some way other than the bravado and the
song so you have to just stay consistent
with what your image is in your personal
life and in your business you really
seem to have kept your ego in check how
have you done that I'm going to just
stand close enough to people from the
beginning my relationships early on like
I have friends that I've always been my
friend so they see me one way it's known
they see what I do for a living and it's
a magician and then they thought they
know everything about me prior to any of
the financial changes I can remember the
last time we met up you had some of your
friends with him guys that had grown up
with you for a long time and you know
when I interview a lot of celebrities
particularly african-american
celebrities they talk about that
transition when they went through that
initial stage wealth and how many
friends they lost and the expectations
that people had on them have you gotten
rid of most of that now you went through
that too it's absolutely it's impossible
to get away from it okay no matter what
group of people with us your actual
blood relatives or people that you've
develop relationships over time to
create a value they are this points with
some of them develop a sense of
entitlement and it can't be met but what
they feel like they're entitled to you
can't really do that for them and they
just they get blinded by what you've
done and say that consistently say look
what you have versus acknowledging what
you've already done right what you did
to get what you have right or just what
you've done for them personally oh I see
oh yeah look at it and still be like but
you have to get into that thought
process with but you
so much so you know if you consider a
bit more like like and you go right but
what makes you think what makes you feel
like I'm supposed to have to do this way
right I don't know I got uncle's I got
uncle's like I can't stand them
relatives did I just it hurts me to have
to be there when my grandmother she sees
they must go through her for things and
everything has a sweet maybe she's the
one so it's like in if this function
like family function I go because she's
gonna be disappointed by our show and
it's play stood there and it's like
uh-uh
I know that y'all don't like me like
please don't what are you gonna ask me
for now yeah but therein lies part of
the connection correct me if I'm wrong
between you and Floyd Mayweather that he
too had gone into well fast but put in a
lot of hard work to get there had a
falling-out with his father but continue
to move forward and you guys a lot of
people can't relate to that experience
so is that part of your initial
connection that you had with Floyd
Mayweather that you had similar
circumstances that it is a huge passion
for music
Floyd's been following me since 2002
like everything that comes out you know
he knows all of it all alerts all the
music this is a little unsecured so it
isn't even one shared spotlight with his
dead sit on sanding is could be about
Floyd that's all it's there's no any
other issues between it like that's
don't get it wrong when you say like cuz
floated somebody it's like it's like my
brother so a fallout we have attitude or
go after each other one day and then the
next day you'll call we talk to each
other and that's cool to hear that yeah
is it possible that you could become
friends with him again what we're always
gonna be fine okay right like we're
friends now like there's never like we
never stopped being friends which it was
publicly the public was being made aware
of an argument oh I see okay
so you know you're one of the Masters
the master marketers in hip-hop one of
the things that you do is you can take a
conflict and you can make that thing
last for a year and by the time it's
over you've made money on it well not
necessarily money on the actual argument
up that what that does is create brand
equity it creates that barbershop beauty
salon conversation it keeps the things
that you're doing in conversation and
communication because they're talking
about one thing that argument because
people love that as much as they say
they don't like the conflict they like
them statistic United State they really
enjoy the point with is some sort of
friction is there like balance always
been a part of hip-hop culture
mm-hmm call it beef and now because
we're using the same terminologies
they'd be using the environment
artistically artists that had those
strong influences in the upbringing
brought that to the art form but when
nothing negative happens when it doesn't
spill out into the actual street than
you know was just being competitive or
the source of why that actual beef took
place one is I don't like how you look
at look at me then you know it's about
the person feeling like they're ready to
compete with you for an actual position
and all of this is established artists
being attacked by a new guy that wants
to really come up yeah when you came up
you did that you were you were the dude
I can remember when you came out with
your initial makeup and you were
everybody was talking about you you were
talking about everybody else you were
almost feared and fearless that was
desperation also okay you know hunger
that was via Columbia Records and they
didn't actually understand what I was as
an artist I recorded 36 songs in 18 days
and Bearsville upstate New York working
with the track masters and when we got
back there was like okay we're going
through the deal then
we got the album I'm like no no that's
what I was going to show you how I can
write no problem that's not the actual
album I got ideas for the record the way
I want my album in the sound how did
they take that I mean it took a little
time for me to get the ideal because
they felt like they finished out you had
36 songs we got the album because it was
happy with what I performed on the
production that we had available at that
point but I was like no that's not what
I would do is my album that was what I
was doing to actually get the deal so
what that really turned out to be was
innovation of the new model of the
mixtape and how the mixtape is that true
or the mixtape came after I didn't have
the ability to be mocked and promoted by
Columbia Records following being shot in
2000 when I recovered like I spent a lot
of time with Columbia Records I learned
a lot that experience for me it was like
I spent time with everybody from Nikki
Martin to Mark Jordan to OJ woman and
footy in the street team and radio
department linear nicholson and rich
nice and all space julian in art
department i learned all of the actual
job functions during that time period so
when i lost the ability to be marketing
promoted by columbia mm-hmm i figure out
how to build momentum on my own so i put
out a few things for promotional
purposes on mixtapes they were done
traditionally how a freestyle would be
done it started to get attention from
people from hip hop country because it
had the same message in points same
aggression that I had on material prior
to being shot and it were like this is
the real deal because there's no
adjustment like they know this is where
you get hurt as bad as I got her in 2000
near the efficient swimming pool you
become a bit of sensitive a lot of
people would not have taken the
opportunity to learn with you were
thrust into this opportunity and it
seems like from being around Jimmy
Iovine
being around just if you've absorbed and
paid attention and been a critical
thinker you could take advantage of that
and turn yourself into what you are but
that's hard to do very very I mean if
you don't have a lot of examples in
front of you you're not actually in a
position to utilize what you just
learned I kind of hold onto it until
you're in a position that runs parallel
to timing all right and particularly
like every artist that hands you a
mixtape at this point it's doing
something that's a reflection of what I
did and what I came up with in a period
that everyone was afraid to be
associated with hmm so how does that
affect you it feels good okay
they don't understand that I'm flattered
by them all following the concept lion
king I didn't Puffy's contribution to
hip-hop culture was dreamings he offered
went did the licensing paid for the
samples and put artists like biggie mace
and a lots and other artists on
production that his mom played out the
front mm-hm
you know I mean it was older hit records
that he brought back with new drums and
new production around it and now when
you hear remix they're doing something
that puffy implemented and for me I
didn't want to be put back into the
batch of artistic and rap toucan song
right and because the most talented
rappers in my eyes are battling each
other they say really well-thought-out
punchlines about each other and they
can't write a song to save their life so
I focused on mines for song structure
even on mixtape efforts hmm and the
bootleggers it was new they never saw
that before so when it came out because
it sounds like a record is good they
both like the right mm-hmm and it made
all of the actual
distribution of music my marketing team
unbelievable so now how much wrapping
are you doing
I had a day-to-day basis do you wrap
these days you do here is now I've been
writing new material since I started to
release my actual album I usually make
two albums worth of material to give
away during the process of selling an
actual record because it's taken a lot
longer the position records then they
use tool used to take six to eight weeks
and radio and now it's like twelve you
know like it's almost twice the length
of time so because if our poacher has a
like I said au feu driven audience that
has a low attention span they're not
sure that it's smoking-hot because it
would take six weeks for it to be at
that peak point with everywhere in front
of you now it's taking 12 weeks and
they're going like that but I'm
overwhelmed I'm not sure if it's as hot
as those other records because it's just
a different climate in time so if I was
coming up now I find the visual to be
more important or as important as the
actual song yourself because your phone
has the ability to be your recording
device for your in studio performance
and if you have the right material you
start to generate interest or develop a
fan base and you have limit listen also
people online they can begin to check
you out based on that you would have
done it differently you would have had
because it just your strategy was genius
and when I like I used to talk to Chris
lighty rest in peace and the fact that
you guys did this together and you moved
about and saw the corporate side we're
going to get money literally on that
corporate side it's not it like it
hadn't been done before but you guys
really did it in a different way who
does that for you now in the absence of
we're kind of utilizing people that have
always been there uh-huh like the entire
record company with junior records that
huge roster of artists to look after at
the same time and now that we're kind of
regrouping to bring on new talent you
know it allows the staff is there to
focus to charm in on the 50 cent project
law as a businessman how did the loss of
Chris affect you well I mean he was
someone that would take all of our
initial meetings for new opportunities
and then kind of sorted out before this
even brought to my attention so it's
definitely a huge adjustment to make but
I'm not afraid of change so you know it
was I wasn't prepared for it you know it
was definitely awkward and uncomfortable
you know that to go to that but I'll
make the adjustments you know right
whatever it is like in my life I've had
to do that like this always a constant
there'll be a change there'll be
something else to just goes wow this is
not going to be like this tomorrow I'm
completely different and how do you
figure it out and like the record
company itself music business is
shifting so dramatically that you go
let's figure out how to do it and it's
not going to be our outline for you to
actually do it the right way somebody's
going to have to work and find a new way
so I feel like I'm the guy all the time
with so much that we could talk about so
little time but I really now want to
focus just a little bit before we wrap
up on your future because so your
narrative is so strong leading up to
this point but the opportunity now for
you is vast because you've gone through
that initial period of getting used to
being a wealthy famous guy
with me whether he's a guy I saw you
guys acting like you were talking on the
phone with stacks on my butt right and
there's so much about his opulence and
how much money he spends when he goes
places I don't get that sense about you
I feel like maybe you went through that
period at some point but you let go of
that the opposites on
it okay and to think you know I don't
have to I think you should be interested
in me just because me and Floyd keeps
the things around them that would make
you interested in anyone everything is
representation of those things the only
1% of us should have and he does it a
level that forces you to been to put
places if people are watching Floyd
fight I'm not necessarily watching it
for them to win it's because we're in
the middle of a recession and the
messaging points are we have all the
money in the world to spend it nothing
matters you'll want to see that guy lose
he said I'm saying they did the
difference between Muhammad Ali in Floyd
like I live with socially conscious and
the People's Champ and Floyd is the
villain you know because he's the guy
that is dead that they see in the
financial space this a dream sequence
and they seem flowing it like it's not
okay so as you come into your your new
next chapter in life I watched the Oprah
interview and I remember the point when
she asked you you said you mentioned
meditating I said you meditate yes I was
surprised she was really surprised
because a lot of people just don't know
that level of evolution so now what's
next I mean I asked you last time if you
want to be a billionaire yeah I'm not
interested in the financial our coastal
want to continue success but there's no
specific mark mmm-hmm finances do the
work because to be honest with you if
I'm sitting here with you a year from
now two years from now and they like you
did it you're a billionaire i'ma still
be saying it but I got another idea
right a new idea and it's what I think
is representation of a person who is
truly ambitious because ambition isn't a
learned behavior it's a part of your
natural character and you always find
something to be passionate about our new
goal or new you see guys tell companies
five six billion dollars and go yeah
okay now what's the next one where you
see that
because you're in that world now you're
able to get access to those guys and
talk to them about that's the difference
is truly Sam because you're moving to
different social classes based on your
accomplishments you know you just fall
into the new rooms with with new people
in them that have accomplished so much
that they'll minimize your
accomplishments your look and go okay I
need to go to work
did you see what's going on was there
ever a point where you saw certain
things like maybe you met a Warren
Buffett or Bill Gates or someone and
talked to them and started to think wow
now this is what we need to do this is
what I want to do well not not sure
Warren Buffett's or Bill Gates those are
the guys that I like figures for that
but you know there's a lot of
billionaires that out there there aren't
as notable and then when you figure out
how they did it you go like that so are
they willing to share with you yeah
that's Dell it's like all right you're
at the light funny be sitting in that
position till I get you hooked to the
light and a Bentley you got a moose on
you just a let's move 2013 and I pull up
at the light and a hoopty I'm gonna
dodge $93 Caravan I didn't wash it and
I'm telling you rose window down roll
the window down and you look over and
you don't grow your window down he won't
roll this window then take the same
scenario you put that guy and up and
that Bentley at the light and the guy
pulls up next to him and the Ferrari
says eight old window down the world
window down this was a choice mm-hmm but
he feels like you may have something to
say value to me just on presentation so
you know like I say this to younger
actual you know guys out there to kind
of fit the description I thought I was
going somewhere and it wasn't I have to
be conscious of it I can't do the
three-piece when I'm there as for
descent
mmm-hmm because then the audience will
look at you like their parents instead
of the actual artists that they
appreciate you know but if you actually
want to make the window roll down you
have to fit the description you've kind
of struck a good balance between both
now yeah well when it's time to you know
make those relationships and to talk
business up more Curtis than 57 and so
now when you're in this existence and
you're looking at new opportunities and
you have all kinds of ideas and then
Obama comes along and says we need to
tax the millionaires and billionaires
does that affect you because you just
got here
yeah but the money ten years my guys you
know from someone okay all right we got
a you know make adjustments if not if
you leave it the way it is and it's just
bad then what it affects you then also
like you know like I wouldn't be here if
the general public didn't make those
projects of success well they didn't
have the finances at that point to go
purchase the materials or they had to
make a choice like I could pay my rent
and the cable bill or I could go to the
actual show I'm paying my rent the cable
bill up you don't me before I go see the
artists at live like so those decisions
when they get to those points then you
know you got I'd rather them tax people
that can afford to be taxed then to just
declare the lights out for you know the
entire middle class and then where I'm
from the original recession the checks
are still coming on the first it's the
same balance there's no money there to
begin with
so they look and go oh yeah we in
recession when there is don't went but
when you have money and then you are
affected by a recession that hunger that
you mentioned in
beginning that made you who you are how
do you recreate that experience to make
sure you stay hungry or do you not need
to do that I don't think it's about
actually the money at that point because
once you're actually at acquire
something you start to realize things
about yourself like you don't need
things that you work that you want it
because the the big restraint in front
of you when you're not in the financial
space is financial like you answer to
what would make this better is and if I
have some money but I mean in the
psychology has been used even the market
magazines everything you walk touch the
newsstand and show you that dream car
with a woman this representation of
codes and standards of beauty that made
translate as a dream also so the
psychology is if I get a car like that I
get that kind of woman the draws even
more interest in the financial side form
from male like when you put in tradition
they would say the male's responsible to
be the financial support of the actual
family and a woman who is there to
create a serene space for them to escape
the pressures of the work environment
that's the traditional relationship to
my grandparents actually out and that's
why that's a attractive woman beside the
car versus attractive man hmm
if you don't see any men on those
publications this representation of
something a woman should be interested
in buying an actual car pick a male
child when a young that off from cars
trucks all those things relate to
finance female child and all for baby
while she's a baby doll house or cooking
set think subconsciously teaching the
nurtures nurturing and prepare enough
for reproduction you're very perceptive
about the nuances of marketing and how
you know one thing you can go and you
can read a harvard thesis about it I'm
sure you have about marketing but you
understand demographics the demographic
swings that Romney missed right how
things are changing
in America and how to capitalize on that
where did you how did you develop that
sense well just trying to pay attention
to why things were happening the way or
what happening for me in my career you
know and away from having interest in
selling other things or being associated
with companies there were marketing
products to the general public it it was
just how do I continue success from the
perspective that I had successful at
that point pay attention to that and
then it grows outside of that actual box
because yet expectations you start to
anticipate such successful different
projects and different levels and come
across new information it gives you an
understanding of how things actually
work like working with poor firemen that
are BK and in response to losing the
bidding war for LeBron James who did
lifestyle branding myself jay-z daddy
yankee for the artisan when you see that
the successful actually she was at
different points I gotta put my shoe at
a price point that I knew everyone was
comfortable with paying that amount the
Haiti dollars the same price point over
here fourth one you know and other
artists did different things with their
brands based on how they want they
branded be received mm-hmm you know so
they marketed as solar shoes at higher
price points you know and I just had an
interest in going mass at that point
because I wanted to see the actual shoe
on people feet when I was out hmm you
know because it would be representation
of the brand and I still was focused on
music at that point okay well your
publicist is telling me that we need to
wrap it up just one final question you
mentioned jay-z and LeBron and all of
these guys similarly situated guys will
you do a deal with them one day I mean
yeah Dylan harpy will work together on
some levels at some point project come
along
Jay Z actually owe me a favor because I
did commercial but sneak out of UK so
I'm gonna be I'm gonna run into him he's
gonna return that favor all right man
Curtis Jackson it's always a pleasure to
see you keep up the good work come back
and see us we congratulate you on your
new book and all your business ventures
boxing everything you're doing thank you
and with Curtis Jackson I'm Lee Hawkins
we'll see you next time that voice right
there that's it that's why you here say
that again
and with Reggie Jackson I'm Lee hawkers
we'll see you next time
and with the auctions I'm Curtis Jackson
I'll see you next time things private